from bloomberg quick take i'm madison
mills joined today by dr anthony fauci
the nation's foremost infectious disease
expert
who perhaps would rather be a bit less
famous than he is right about now
dr fauci thank you so much for making
the time to join us today
just to kick us off how are you doing
how are you holding up
um i'm fine this is obviously a very
intense time for the entire world
uh and our country and that certainly
gets reflected on
what what we have to do our
responsibility it's very intense but you
know it is
you know it's something we just have to
do we can't walk away from it it's
it's a tough situation and i want to
dive right in because we don't have a
ton of time together uh dr fauci if you
could wave
a magic wand and have three major
changes happen in the u.s whether that
was
universal testing or more contact
tracing better health care
what would those three changes be well
you know it probably would be
one change that maybe has multiple
elements to it
i would like to see a uniform
uh pulling together in the country
to both depreciate the need for and
implement the things that we need to do
to get that baseline level of community
spread
way way down one of the problems that
we've had
is that if you look at the curves that
have gone up and was driven early on by
the northeast
particularly the new york metropolitan
area and then they started to come down
but as they were coming down and getting
down to quite a very low baseline which
is good
there were other states in other regions
particularly in the south
who as they tried to open up and get the
economy back
did it in a way that was not uniform it
was a bit disjointed some did it well
some didn't do it
so well some try to do it well the
people didn't listen
to the kinds of guidelines that were put
forth
and then we had that increase that went
up from a already high baseline
of 20 000 cases a day up gradually to
at one point over 70 000 cases
per day getting the deaths back over
a thousand a day we come back down now
to 40 or 50 000 cases a day which is
still extraordinarily high
as a baseline so i would have liked to
have seen the kinds of
uniform pulling together as a nation we
live in a big country
a beautiful country a wonderful country
that's very heterogeneous
in so many ways but here's a time when
you really have to be
pulling together as one so when you're
talking about
the things you need to do to prevent the
surges of infection
as well as to blunt the surges that have
already
occurred it's those kind of five or six
things you know
uniform wearing of masks keeping
distance six feet or more
avoiding crowds being in a situation
where you are you know washing hands as
frequently
as you possibly can and outdoor things
always better than indoor things if we
all did that in a uniform way
we would prevent these surges that we're
seeing and it's unfortunate
because once you have one go down then
all of a sudden
another one comes up i mean the southern
states that were surging
are turning around doing the kinds of
things like arizona
which are really making a difference and
as that's happening
there are other states sometimes in the
yellow zone
that are starting to tick up and i just
hope we don't see that kind of surging
go up
otherwise it's going to be bumpy up and
down instead of a clear cut
down to a baseline that would be very
manageable but we're not there yet
and dr fauci you mentioned cases in the
south uh would it be worthwhile for some
of these red states that you mentioned
to go back
into lockdown yeah you know i'm not so
sure you really need to go to lockdown i
mean obviously
that's always on the table for
consideration but i would think you
don't need to do that for so many
reasons because we do know
when you implement the five or so things
that i just mentioned
that you do see very tangible results
of the curves turning around and coming
down
and the prevention of those coming up so
i mean
a lockdown obviously with all the
psychological uh
and morale destruction that that would
do it would be tough
i mean you never want to rule anything
out that you might have to do
but i'm i'm fairly convinced that we
could get to where we want to be without
doing that
if everyone as i said in answer to your
first question madison
if everybody pulled together and we're
doing things in a uniform consistent way
and abiding by the guidelines for
opening the country i mean i've said
this many times and i'll
i welcome saying it again that we could
use
good public health practices as a
vehicle
a gateway a facilitating
the opening up of the economy and
opening up the country
some people look upon that as an
obstacle
to opening up the country it doesn't
have to be an obstacle
if done in a prudent careful way it
could help us
to open up the country dr fauci one of
those
five to six recommendations you speak
about a lot is of course
mask wearing uh we know that if we had a
universal
compliance uh with wearing masks that
our numbers would be better so
have you considered pushing the
president to invoke a federal mass
mandate
well i i don't think that's going to
occur madison because you know there's a
a reluctance to have federal mandates
for so many reasons
um you know would it have people
actually push
back against it how do you enforce it
you mean i
as a public health person and as a
physician and a scientist
would strongly strongly encourage people
anywhere and everywhere in our country
to understand the importance
of mass squaring social distancing
avoiding crowds the kinds of things
that i mentioned it's critical it's not
something
that's going to prevent us from
ultimately opening
to the fullest it's going to get us
there
you talk about uh potential pushback to
one of these
federal mandate of mask wearing um but
there are other things that we do
enforce federally every day so why would
mask wearing be different
you know i uh madison i'm telling you it
isn't like i don't think we should do it
i'm just telling you it's not going to
happen
i mean that's the point i mean we could
talk back and forth about
all the advantages or what have you for
it i just don't think it's going to
happen
fair enough uh i'm wondering also if we
can talk a bit about testing
um admiral brett gerard has said that if
we do too much testing it could
overwhelm the system potentially
cause schools to question reopening
where do you stand on that
well you know i think people need to
understand that there's there's two
types
of testing what what admiral girard was
talking about overwhelming the system
was the testing that is done in response
to trying to do identification isolation
contact tracing
that there's testing that needs to be
done according
to the kinds of guidelines and and and
plan that one puts forth
about how you address cases then there's
another kind of testing that's
surveillance testing
where people want to find out in a given
area
be that a region a state a county or
even
a factory or a school or what have you
that kind of surveillance testing
if that's done in a way that doesn't
compete
with the day-by-day necessary testing
that you need to do
to definitively identify someone who's
infected
as opposed to surveillance to kind of
get a feel
for what the penetrance is if we could
do a lot of surveillance testing
without interfering with any of the
other testing i'm all for that
madison i've been for that from the
beginning
of being able to do that quick easy
testing that is scalable without
interfering
with the identification isolation
contact tracing
type of testing that you do you don't
want one
system to overwhelm the other
and let's talk a bit about vaccines uh
you've mentioned that we can expect
a potential vaccine by 2021. i'm
wondering what life will look like when
we do have that vaccine will we be
ripping our masks off
and running back to the office what will
day-to-day life look like
that's a good question and it's going to
depend very much
on what the percent or level
of efficacy of the vaccine is i mean if
you know very few there aren't any
vaccines that are 100 protected
the really really amazingly good
vaccines
are vaccines like measles which is 97 to
98
effective which means once you get that
you'd get immediately a degree
of hurt immunity that the entire
community will be protected
we don't know what the level of efficacy
is going to be
we hope it's going to be somewhere
around 70 75
i mean i'll take 97 any day of the year
i'm not so sure we're going to get there
uh i i would be
very happy with 70 75 and i would be
accepting
of 50 to 60 because that would be value
added superimposed upon
and complementary to public health
measures
so if we don't get a vaccine that is
highly highly highly effective even
though
it would still be a good vaccine i think
we would have to have
some degree of attention to public
health measures
i don't think it's going to be we have a
vaccine in 2021
forget it you can do everything you want
to do you don't have to worry about any
of the public health
recommendations i don't think it's going
to be that way i think
ultimately we will get to that
but i don't think it's going to be as
soon as the vaccine comes
because it's going to take a while to
build up
a cumulative amount of immunity either
induced by the vaccine
or by natural infection to get to the
point where you really have a veil
of protection or an umbrella of
protection
over the community that's not going to
happen in the first
couple of months of availability of
vaccine
so we will not be able i hope we don't
we
should not abandon public health
measures
even when we do get a vaccine
you talk about uh being happy with 50 to
70
effectiveness with vaccine can we just
go back to the science of what that
means for our audience
um can you can you explain what you mean
by those numbers yeah that means that
you know when you compare
the persons who are vaccinated versus
not the protection
is 50 of that would be in other words
you 50
more than if you didn't get any at all
sure the easiest way to understand if
you get 100
protection everybody's protected okay
that's what it means i mean
that's simple as that but we're not
going to get there we're going to be
like 50
of the people or 70 of the people will
be protected
and we got a lot of audience questions
in in advance of this interview about
the potential russia vaccine putin is
pushing the head of regulators on it
if that vaccine doesn't go very well
how could that impact overall
trustworthiness in vaccines more
globally
well you know i i that's a very good
question
that's why i'm quite disturbed
by russia or any country which declares
they have a vaccine before they've
adequately tested it
because that would that would really
impart upon
i guess the rest of the world if it
turns out that the vaccine isn't safe
i mean there are two things about a
vaccine you want you want it to be safe
and you want it to be effective now if
you get a vaccine that you make and you
decide you're going to distribute it
before you have shown that it is safe
and before you've shown
that it's effective that there are two
aspects of that
that are really problematic one if it's
not safe you're really in trouble
because you're going to be giving it to
hundreds of millions
of people and this possibility that
shall harm them
and then if it's not effective you get
people thinking they're protected
and they're not which would modify their
behavior
so that's why i'm very very concerned
when you hear about
a vaccine being developed but then being
distributed
without having adequately tested it
which is the reason why
of the vaccine candidates that are being
tested
in our country and in several other
countries that there is a very very
strong
emphasis placed on proving that it is
safe
and proving that it's effective before
you make a decision
to widely distribute it because with
vaccines
unlike drugs which are giving to a
person
who may be sick who needs the drug
you're distributing vaccines
globally to billions of people
who are healthy people or people
who you don't want to make sick with the
vaccine
that's why we emphasize safety very
strongly
and you've already started a community
information effort around the vaccine
trials uh
and as you mentioned that there is some
concern about vaccines particularly in
the u.s so what is your plan for sort of
rallying people
behind supporting a vaccine once it's
developed well
there well that's a good question
madison but there are two aspects of
that
first of all you want to make sure that
in the
testing of the vaccine before it is
approved
to be safe and effective you want to get
an
equitable type of a distribution
representative
of your society you don't want to test
it in one demographic group and then
assume
that it's safe and effective in another
demographic bloof it likely will be
but you'd like to see good
representation of people of different
ages
different sexes and different race and
ethnic
backgrounds that's what you want to do
because once you prove
that it is safe and effective in a
representative
group of people in the country when you
want to distribute it
after it's been approved to be safe and
effective
you can say that i've adequately tested
it
representatively in each of these groups
once you do that then you've got to have
what you alluded to a moment ago
is community engagement and community
outreach
to be very transparent about the results
of the trial
and to try and convince people to
understand why it's important for them
and important for society for them to
get vaccinated
and you know particularly in situations
where you have minority groups
african-americans
latinx and others particularly
african-americans who historically
have not been treated well by the
medical and public health community
if you look at like tuskegee and and
incidences like that
we've got to make sure that they
understand that this has been
very very carefully tested and we're
doing it because we want to
protect the entire nation not just one
group versus the other
and you bring up a great point about
reaching out to minority communities we
know that covet 19 is disproportionately
impacting black americans what can be
done to specifically address that health
disparity
well i mean there are things that one
can do immediately
and there are things that are so deeply
ingrained in society that it's going to
take
a commitment over decades to do so if
you look at
the african-american latinx and and
other even other minority communities
by the very nature of the kinds of jobs
as a group they generally have you don't
like to generalize but in this case it's
appropriate to
that african americans and latinx
often don't have the capability of
having a job
where they can be safe so that they can
separate themselves physically
they're often in those on the line in
the trenches jobs
that puts them in contact which on the
one hand puts them at an increased risk
of getting infected in the first place
once they get infected then you have the
situation because of many of the social
determinants of health
over decades and decades they have a
higher incidence
of the co-morbidities or the other
diseases
which put them at greater risk of having
a
poor outcome of infection and those are
things like diabetes
hypertension obesity chronic
kidney disease chronic lung disease
the incidence and prevalence of those
comorbidities
in the minority populations is greater
than the general population so i always
say
they have a double whammy negative
against them
something you can do now for that is you
can make sure that
in those areas be they count these
cities
region states where you have a
demographic over-representation
of minorities that you have facilities
of
testing to be done rapidly and carefully
so that they can enter into health care
if they need it
as quickly as possible so you want a
concentration
of those resources now in the long run
how you overcome those kinds of factors
that have led
to the increase in a variety of
comorbidities
is going to take a commitment that
really looking forward
decades because it took decades to get
there
you want to take a commitment of decades
to get out of it
you mentioned the impact of covid on
folks with specific jobs and that makes
me think of teachers and schools
reopening
i'm wondering how confident you are that
schools and what you call
green zones will be able to remain open
uh and how worried are you about school
reopenings causing outbreaks
well again i i think you just ticked off
the first part of that madison that
that is is the thing that is sometimes
confusing to people
in that you can't look at this country
when you're talking about schools and
we're talking about elementary middle
and high school
universities are a different story you
can't look at it
in a unidimensional way because we have
a big country
that differing differs considerably in
the level of infection
in different regions states cities
counties so if you are in
a green zone you can't just say okay
we're safer in a green zone forget
everything you've still got to have
the kinds of precautions but you can
open up the schools
relatively easily when you're in an area
where there are very very few
infections it gets a little bit more
tricky when you get into the yellow zone
namely one in which you have a
five to ten percent test positivity and
a ten to a hundred per hundred thousand
uh um uh cases that
you need to take a look at the school
and at the local level to make
the decision based a lot on the cdc
recommendations about what can you do
to mitigate the possibility and the
chance of infection and of spreading of
infection
that could be hybrid we do some online
some in person you can have part outdoor
classes
you can alternate days morning afternoon
you know i don't want to prescribe that
now
but locally there are some creative ways
of doing that
but when you're in a red hot red zone
you really better be careful
before you just throw children back even
though the principle
and the default position which i've
always said should be
that you should try as best as you
possibly can
to get children back to school for the
reasons we're very familiar with
that the american academy of pediatrics
has articulated
because of the mental and psychological
health of the children
because of the fact that some children
rely on school
for nutrition for breakfast and for
lunch as well as the downstream
negative effects on families who may
have to modify
severely their work schedule to be able
to take care of the children
so you should try to do that but
underlying that and the however and the
butt about that
is that you absolutely need to pay
attention
to the health the welfare and the safety
of the children
of the teachers and the people
associated with them
so you can't make a decision for the
country
as a whole you've got to look at where
you are
in the context of the level of infection
that you're dealing with
and trump's new coronavirus advisor dr
scott atlas has been a big proponent of
returning to schools um have you spoken
with him
well i have had a brief conversations
with him i'm actually going to have uh
somewhat extended conversation with him
later on today
to try and you know get a feel for where
we are with regard to these
issues and do we differ and if so how
much
i i'm looking forward to that
conversation
what's your main goal for that
conversation you touched on it briefly
but do you have any other goals coming
out of that
no what i would like to see is actually
you know you hear a lot about what
people are saying about what they think
and what they feel
i'm of the bent i've always been to just
go right to the source
and have an open honest conversation
about how you feel about certain issues
what your recommendations would might be
and i'll tell you what mine are
hopefully we can come to some sort of
you know
agreement if you want to call it that
we'll see i mean i'm just leaving a
completely
open mind in my discussion with him
and i'm also curious when was the last
time you uh were able to speak with
president trump about
kovid it was a few days ago last
last week i believe it was i briefed him
about vaccines
you know what this time it wasn't a long
time ago it was it was within a week or
so
uh i would say probably within a week
and i have a few more uh vaccine-related
questions for you dr fauci before we let
you go here um how soon can we expect
preliminary results on the nih moderna
vaccine
you know you you can't expect it may
occur
if that's that's the main lesson we've
learned in this pandemic you can't
expect anything right
i'll explain it's it's a process that's
a time
honored process whenever you have a
vaccine trial
uh in any trial not only badarna but all
the trials you establish what's called
an
independent data and safety monitoring
board
referred to as a dsmb and it's an
independent group
of statisticians scientists community
people
what they do is that they independently
look at the data
on an intermittent basis and they can
determine
and they're independent and they make
the recommendations
either the trial is going fine continue
it
it doesn't look like you're going to get
an answer it's futile you better stop it
things are so bad you better stop it or
things are so good that you should stop
it now because the results are so
favorable
and they look at it every you know
periodically every
month or two or what have you sometimes
even more frequently
and then when they come to that
determination usually
the determination is things are going
well continue the trial
that's what you almost certainly are
going to get from the first
determination that the dsmd looks at but
that's very standard
procedure with all these vaccine trials
and similarly how close are we to having
a strain that would enable human
challenge
trials and how could that help us get
closer to a vaccine yeah
you know i think there's a misperception
that human traff uh
challenge trials with with uh with the
sauce coronavirus
ii is going to get us to the end point
where we want to be sooner
you're not going to get the strain in a
in a shape that's you know what's called
good uh good uh manufacturing practices
that the fda would even allow you to put
into someone probably
for several months several months
which means that hopefully we'll have an
answer
from the trials itself that you won't
even have to revert
to a human challenge study i would say
when people ask me and i mean that
given all the potential difficulties
because we don't yet
have adequate therapies for that we
still don't know
the full scope of the disease and what
the chronic
long-term effects are we're very
reluctant to do that unless it's
absolutely essential
so that's not even my plan b to me
that's
nc or plan d
and more broadly what does success look
like for you and for the country uh how
will we know that we have the virus
under control
and in places like new york or other
states that have started to get it under
control a bit more
um will we see a resurgence in the fall
potentially
well i mean that's what we're trying to
avoid and the easiest way to avoid it
getting back to what i said
during the beginning of the interview
madison is to get down
to as low a baseline as possible
so that the percent positive of the test
you do
is like one percent or less at the most
two
in that line you don't want to go into
the fall
where parts of the country have a
percent positive in double digits
that means that the virus is still
around and around in full force
and then if you get into a winter we
have people spending more time indoors
more difficult to control
the spread of a respiratory borne
illness that could be a problem
so we have a window of opportunity now
and that's the thing i keep saying let's
jump all over that window now
to be able to as a nation to pull
together in a consistent prudent way
to control this at the same time as
we're
carefully and prudently trying to open
up the economy and open up the country
and you've shared a lot of your
recommendations with us today i'm
wondering
when your recommendations are at odds
with the president
how do you navigate that discussion how
do you decide what to share with the
american people
uh and can you kind of take us into what
those discussions look like
uh you know no actually not because you
know when you have a
personal one-on-one discussion with the
president it's just not a good idea
to then go out and tell everybody what
it was you'll hear from me
very clearly and firmly what my
recommendations are
and then i mean obviously you'll be
hearing from other people
uh hopefully we're all on the same tune
in the same page
so there won't be any confusion
and moving on to the election i'm
wondering uh you've spoken about how
voting in person is potentially similar
to going to the grocery store
um but is there any upside to
encouraging mail-in voting just to avoid
any and all risk
you know i mean there should be both in
my mind i mean i i
i was asked about i mean mail-in voting
is a policy issue
in-person voting you know people ask the
public health aspects of that
you know when i use the example when you
try to go to a grocery store or to a
starbucks
you see the x's on the floor stay here
and don't move until that
x is empty i mean that's good i mean
that's what people are doing i think
if you have mask wearing and you have a
situation where
people in the polls are also being
careful
hand sanitizers i think you could safely
vote
in person i also think for people who
can't do that
for one reason or other who are
concerned about doing that
they should be able to vote by mail
dr patrick we only have a couple minutes
left with you so uh
two quick fun questions for you um
you've been very
heavily embraced by gen z and the
internet and turned into
um a lot of very fun memes i'm wondering
did you ever expect
to be so beloved by the under 18
community
in the u.s no
i didn't expect to be so loved by the
under 18
community uh i also didn't expect to be
so hated
by other elements in society which just
proves the divisiveness which we have
i try not to pay attention or
get distracted by either extreme and
just focus
on the job that i'm supposed to be doing
absolutely and i wonder how uh some of
that
negativity is impacting you um
are you able to take care of your mental
health at all during this or is
is is your entire life dedicated to your
work right now
oh it's 110 dedicated to my work um
i i my mental health is fine um
i have a wonderful wife and family who
are very supportive i got
really good friends that are supportive
so i'm fine
i'm fine i mean obviously i'm like
everybody else i'm exhausted but you
know
i've been through medical training as an
intern and resident which you know
is exhaustion that's real exhaustion
well dr fatchi we can't thank you enough
for making the time to join us today
uh for those watching please follow
bloomberg take quick take wherever you
get your news on social media and thank
you so much again dr fauci for your time
thank you for having me appreciate it